the Deputy Chair of the Conservative
Party James cleverly MP this is a
government that's lost it isn't it
you're censored for a contempt in
Parliament a couple of days ago now the
man who was seen fit to be foreign
secretary for two years is having to
grovel to Parliament for not following
the rules Boris isn't in government he
left he was for two years he obviously
thought he was fit to be foreign
secretary and now he's behaving like
this well I work with Boris for best
part of 10 years eight years of which
whilst he was mayor of London and he did
a very very good job at that things like
this it's an oversight these things are
boring the national average wage hasn't
declared these things are boring
bureaucratic to register that but they
are incredibly important you should have
done it he'll make an apology to that I
mean yeah but he was quite happy too
blatant his opinions on the front of the
Telegraph we all knew he was doing it
surely someone who's been foreign
secretary been a senior minister who the
government has felt fit to a point
should be above this sort of behavior he
talked to the wrong guy and I'm you need
to talk to Boris bother
no no I'm talking about a government
which you represent as a party chairman
he was appointed for two years was he a
fit person to be foreign secretary for
two years yes because he was also a fit
person to be Mayor of London did a very
very good job there this is an oversight
I'm not here to defend him you made a
mistake you'll apologize but trying
somehow to wrap this up with what's
going on what about contempt of
Parliament I mean that's another thing
that the government's driven into well
the government made it very very clear
why it feels it's important that
privileged legal advice
it remains private that's a foundation
stone of British law I still think it
was an error on the part of Kerstin to
break that convention it is so very
important that governments can take
discreet advice from their legal
advisers just it's just like with
businesses just like with individuals
but the point about it is your fashion
your own noose by allowing the
resolution through that that evidence
should be released and again it comes
back to governmental competence do you
know what you're doing in the trip
yourself up no that's that's that's not
the case of tools but there's
parliamentary numbers it it was quite
clear that the Labour Party and other
parties were desperate to see that legal
advice
it's now in the public domain and
actually what we've seen is that Jeff
Cox and despatch-box laid out exactly
what people's concerns were about that
legal advice what's actually happened
what Kirsten has done is broken a really
important foundation stone of good
government which is that governments can
take legal advice safe and the knowledge
that it's completely screep and
government should be held to account for
their decisions not based on not not
held to account for for legal advice
that they've received a great important
point now let's shift what the Prime
Minister's been saying this morning
what's new about the fact that MPs will
have a decision whether to extend the
transition period or not well I don't
know if that's finalized yet I've been
hearing reports that that's been even
less discussed on the radio know I was
travelling in I was trying fortunately I
was on a train I wasn't able to there
are mobile phones you know I know but
I've who's not the only thing happening
at the moment it and but what I'm what
my understanding is is that that's one
of the things that's being considered
obviously what the Prime Minister's
focused on is winning the vote
persuading enough yeah parliamentary
colleagues that this is the right way
forward I believe it's the right way
forward yeah it's a deal that delivers
the promises made at the brexit
referendum to leave the EU and we leave
the EU on time this is a really
important point and I'm trying to
understand whether this is a genuine
concession a shift in policy or simply
the Prime Minister standing firm on the
withdrawal agreement she's already
announced well the Prime Minister's made
it the final ministers made it clear
that that the withdrawal agreement is
the culmination of months and months and
months of negotiations not the kind of
thing that's going to be easily or
significantly amendable but obviously
what the Prime Minister is also doing is
exploring with colleagues what their
concerns are what might calm some of
their worries what might give them the
opportunity to support this deal which
gets us out of the EU delivers on what
we promised during the referendum and
does so whilst protecting the integrity
of the United case and as things stand
where do you think
the move of your parliamentary party is
is there any chance at all um to get
this through on Tuesday well there's
always a chance I mean there's no point
in being unrealistic about this or lots
of colleagues have said they're
uncomfortable with the proposal the
Prime Minister the chief whip the the
government are trying to win people over
who have concerns explain to them
Geoffrey Cox is doing that he's done
that the spatch box and and that's what
we will keep doing because ultimately
this is a deal that delivers on the
referendum we need to remind people what
they campaigned on it that's what about
the party your party chair you go out
you get opinion from members and
conservative voters do you think they're
minded to support this deal they are not
massively happy with the deal but then
again I don't think anyone's massively
happy with the deal that's think that's
the nature of negotiated positions they
are very very supportive of the Prime
Minister they want to see us actually
what they want to see us talk more about
is the things that we've been also doing
in government like bringing unemployment
down and bringing employment up wage
growth educational standards more money
for the NHS that you're gonna get past
this hurdle absolutely a leader and
Prime Minister on this do you think we
all know members and activists I'd speak
to up and down the country admire the
Prime Minister massively they are they
are really supportive of her fortitude
they want brexit delivered and this deal
delivers brexit now the other sort of
straw in the wind this morning I can
tell you probably won't have time to see
it the front page of evening standards
right I don't see that one you know
exactly but what it's saying is cabinet
ministers are pressuring the Prime
Minister to pull the deal to not have a
vote on Tuesdays is there any chance of
that I've not heard anything about that
I know some people have been talking
about their program motion has been
voted on I'm not sure whether that's a
credible option and I've not heard
anything about that from number 10 all
the points wouldn't it be better to do
that than suffer a heavy defeat you
think well it's one of these things that
we know as it stands at the moment what
the mood of the house is we're trying to
win people over what would what we're
trying to do is we're trying to remote
people that this deal delivers brexit
that's what we do what what the Prime
Minister does in terms of timings of
votes that that's our tail and what do
you say to your colleagues and their
growing number of them you say look we
vote this down we get hard Brits hit
hard birds it wouldn't be so bad and
that would be the clean rate that people
vote wonderful the point I make to them
is that there are people in the labour
party who have expressly you know
they've expressed their desire to either
delay brexit bring in a second
referendum or stop brexit altogether
they're voting down this deal because
they believe it's the best way to stop
brexit so people who think it's gonna be
a WTO brexit people who believe it's
gonna stop wrecks it they cannot both be
right so it's a gamble taking and I
don't think it's a gamble worth taking
which is why I've been supporting the
deal because one of the things I do know
is this deal delivers what I campaigned
on bringing back control of our borders
our laws our money protecting the
integrity of the United Kingdom and
making sure businesses know what's going
on they can plan for the future
except that backstop doesn't does it I
mean that well it gives European Union
indefinite veto on our trade policy well
we can we can have a big extended debate
yeah we can summarize the five days of
debate this morning but the point is the
EU have said they don't like the
backstop Greeks
it breaks one of their cardinal rules
that you can't separate the customs
union from immigration control and money
so they don't like it we don't like it
none of us want to be in it and so what
we should be focusing on is what
delivers for brexit both for the UK
gives businesses certainty but also
works for the EU and and just finally
we're going to hear from the
Chancellor's Exchequer opening the third
day of the debate okay now he's on
record basically as saying all the
options of leaving the European Union
including with this deal in economic
terms I'm not talking about the
advantages and taking back control of
rates but in economic terms are going to
leave the country
worse off than had it remain did you
agree with that well he's the he's the
maths expert but you got a look at the
figures look at the figures even though
even on the most pessimistic projections
and trust me the Treasury are black
belts in pessimism even on the most
pessimistic it is a less than
quarter of 1% per year over the course
of a decade that's the most pessimistic
and as you say actually a lot of people
have said that that that they are more
passionate about taking back control of
immigration taking back control of our
laws taking back control of our money
because they want it spent on UK
domestic priorities like the NHS and
we've already committed to doing that